FX's just release day season to come
preview so I thought hey why not break
this baby down since it has some awesome
clues as to what's to come if you
haven't seen it yet I've left a link in
the description so give it a look and
come on back the first thing I want to
say is that even though they titled this
season to come
I think the footage here is only from
the next two maybe three episodes I've
said this before but I seriously don't
think the pace of the show can last an
entire 10 episodes which means we might
be in for a big shake-up midseason this
could mean a time jump or a switch to an
entirely different setting if you go on
to IMDB you'll notice that the episode
titles for episode 6 to 10 have not been
named and the description for episode 5
Red Dawn States as Twilight broaches the
survivors brace for a final brawl so my
guess is that something big will happen
in episode 5 but enough about that let's
get right into this preview we start
with a man running looking like he's
being chased this is the hiker from
episode 1 the film grain used here
suggests this is a flashback and poor
hiker gets hit by a car again now the
editors here are faking us out trying to
make us think he gets hit by mr. jingles
but if you compare the two trucks the
one driven by mr. jingles in episode 1
and this one you can see they're both
different now it still could be mr.
jingles we do see him later on with the
hiker but it would have to have been in
a different time my crazy theory is that
this hiker is from the original massacre
in the 1970s and has somehow made it to
1984 with no memory of the past it would
explain how confused he looked when he
was told that camp redwood had reopened
we get a few recycled shots of mr.
jingles arriving and dr. hopple also
arrives at the camp who tells Margaret
that jingles has an obsession with her
if you've seen my episode 1 breakdown
you'll know we've theorized that jingles
was framed for the murders and that
Margaret is the real killer
here we see her praying with someone
looming in the background it's not mr.
jingles here no trench coat or bowlegged
feet we also see this shot of Margaret
having survived the massacre and she
tells hopple that even though
she's been warned a psychopath might be
on the loose camp redwood will open as
scheduled at the dock rook comes across
a floating dead body and noticed the
slashes to her face we don't yet know
who this person is but this is probably
what Spurs Brooke to go to Margaret and
tell them they're in danger but Margaret
isn't having any of it here's a lovely
game of spin the bottle where Montana
finally gets some one-on-one action with
Brooke and there goes Trevor with his
pants off again someone turns off the
lights and judging by the well polished
nails this is a woman and if we
backtrack earlier in the preview look
who has the exact same nails Margaret
this is just more evidence that Margaret
is the real killer
now I'm not convinced this neck shot of
the lights going out and near Xavier is
linked to the shutdown we just saw
mainly because this random dude pushes
him away my guess is that this might be
some sort of detective that's been sent
to investigate and he's actually helping
Xavier from the real killer now we have
hopple being attacked by what appears to
be mr. jingles but since we don't see
his face it could be a fake out Montana
and Rita tumble through the forest and
here we have the night stalker about to
stab Brooke now I'm a little conflicted
here because if you stop the frame here
it doesn't look like he's actually gonna
stab her rather the doc you know just to
scare her but in the next scene we do
see her with a stab wound to the
shoulder jingles is seen killing this
man here who I believe is this same
character who grabbed Xavier that we saw
earlier we have what appears to be some
sort of trap which we'll see later and
look at this shot it's mr. jingles
holding a man wearing an identical
raincoat perhaps this was the man we saw
earlier going after hopple we do not
know his identity
Rita tries to flag down help and is
almost run over it could be Xavier here
since we see him in the van but it could
be another fake out I love this shot of
mr. jingles again we don't see his face
but you can see his collection of ears
dangling from his belt
Brooke looks shocked to see something
and we get a few shots of Rey trying to
escape from a pit the most intriguing
one is here in which we do see jingles
pouring gasoline over him which really
puts a wrench in the theory that jingles
is here for a revenge on just Margaret
we do
know that Ray's job is in orderly what
if he was in orderly at the same
hospital mr. jingles was at that could
definitely be gasoline worthy I also
have a ton of questions like how jingles
would have time to make these elaborate
traps so there's obviously someone
helping or other people involved in one
way or another this shot here kind of
confirms it as jingles or at least
someone who's dressed like jingles let's
this motorcyclist leave without chasing
him but I think we'll learn more about
what motivates jingles in the episodes
to come since we get this shot of him at
the insane asylum he probably had
electroshock therapy done to him so who
knows what's going on in his mind and
look here new character doesn't seem to
be having a good time though poor Chet
seems to have found himself in the same
pit that we saw rayon and Xavier is
consoled by what appears to be Montana
we have the Night Stalker spooking the
[ __ ] out of Rita and look here another
ring coat clad dude throwing a Molotov
cocktail into the cabin it looks like
we're gonna have multiple mr. jingles
slash copycat killers I'm wondering if
these trenchcoat guys might be linked to
the Night Stalker and some Satanist cult
now this is great I'm pretty sure this
is jingles fighting the Night Stalker
will get a better shot of this later
where he literally picks him up with
superhuman strength and notice also
another trap in the background
perhaps he saves one of the campers this
way and is defending them by taking on
the Night Stalker and holy [ __ ] another
crazy trap a giant log with spikes on it
we see what I think is the real mr.
jingles here taking a tire iron to the
face of the hiker but again I think this
is a flashback so who knows why the
hiker is being attacked that was a lot
to unpack and honestly I'm not sure if
that raised more questions than it
solved I hope you'll give this video a
like and subscribe with the Belon
because I'll be covering the whole
season of AHS you can also follow me on
twitter at think story whitey and until
next time remember daddy loves you very
much